oh just gotten home after two weeks some
sick as a dog just took some nyquil
I have fallout 76 I can't wait to just
sit here and veg out Oh what oh well I
have to do it's here where's ever seen
it there's oh of course of course I I
haven't seen wreck-it Ralph maybe I
could I could do that that looks fun
I've never seen creed that back I could
tie those in to what's coming up this
week other classics Godfather - you know
Citizen Kane what was that we're gonna
watch which one one more time don't
wanna look hi everyone my name is Tamara
chambers and this is Tamara's never seen
and today I'm keeping November going
with son of the mass there's always one
Tamara's never seen an episode of here
where I'm sitting on the couch sick
wearing a onesie and this is this it's
hard for me to imagine them screwing
this up so so bad but I hear that they
just screwed it up so so bad it's also
hard to imagine it being as good as the
first without Jim Carrey but it's it's
just it's hard to imagine this world
where the sequel to this amazing film is
like one of the worst movies ever but
apparently that's what more dealing with
[Music]
you
can't bleep up with makeup on for this I
was gonna give like a synopsis but how
do you how do you do that I did put a
poll up on Twitter though saying son of
the mask is a just as good as the first
be a disgrace see sorry I blacked out
what sorry I blacked out what one three
percent of people says just as good as
the first and there's a thousand three
hundred ninety five votes so that's like
40 40 40 people
good night Willa when that is wrong it's
the night I also was trying to write
down no to during this movie and my cat
when do you came out and sat on the hand
that I was writing notes with like she
knew she was saving me you guys and I
didn't listen to her movie doesn't
deserve it but she's gonna give one
before I forget such a mad angry it
started off though and you get this
Norse history walk through tour
I liked the tour guy I thought he was
funny he should have been a larger part
I think you should have played every
part in this movie because it was so
poorly cast oh we good Odin you Loki and
I don't remember that being a thing in
the first movie that the mask was
Loki's mask did I just not pay attention
enough or did was that a new addition to
this films it was like a big part of it
Loki and Odin were in this movie a lot
it's just funny to watch now that there
is so much Loki and Odin content in the
Marvel Universe plus it's kind of like
not kind of this extremely watered down
version of it is so weird
then Alan does some Alan
I actually really enjoy Alan
usually I think he's a weirdo
and I like that but he chose to be in
this film and then also chose to do this
in the film
so I don't know you can see them trying
to use the same kind of humor that they
did in the first we know these guys big
hands and you know everything his
eyeballs go out of his head and all this
stuff but it's it's just lame
without Jim Carrey there it's just Alan
turning into the Tasmanian Devil
and yelling where's my mask it just it
doesn't it doesn't add up it doesn't
like it doesn't it no it doesn't Terry
chambers thoughts on son of the mask it
doesn't so low-key Alan is at
this tour because he's trying to find
his mask that he created and Odin is
pissed at him for losing it has caused
too much mischief in the human whoa the
mask is a fake and he's like Oh where's
my mask again that's the Tasmanian devil
and then it cuts to the actual mask
floating down a Scenic River good god
what so then the dog picks it up then we
meet our two leads our Cameron Diaz and
Jim Carrey of it all they're having the
classic dilemma of she wants to have a
baby but he does it what are they gonna
do not making fun of it because that's
the thing that doesn't happen I realise
that it does I'm making fun of it
because they are so unbelievable in this
she's like oh I really want one and
you'd be a great dad he's over here like
a flicking bumbling idiot flicking
fumbling idiot that's what I just said
about sticking to it and he's a terrible
animator and his whole thing is like oh
I wanna be an animator so bad and then
he finally gets the job I'm just jumping
ahead now cuz I'm angry he finally gets
the job and he's terrible at it he's
it's not like he was working so hard on
notice it's like he's just really bad at
everything that he does and so like you
shouldn't get this cool ass job oh and
then the very end you see the show that
he's animated and it's crap it looks
like food fight it's so bad oh okay so
you meet the two midgets they have a
fight over the baby issue
he makes out with his dog Otis Otis
brings him the mask but he took out of
the river and then he puts it on and he
turns into the mask and it was the most
cringy unfunny awkward not fun I how did
they cast this guy I feel like he might
flourish in other environments but as
the follow-up to Jim Carrey in the mask
that they missed the mark so much of it
the script also does nothing for him
he's written as a terrible character at
the end like the whole resolution is
like him and his baby come together and
it's like all of this movie was to show
that you're a good daddy no one cares
about that I want to see the weirder
wackiness of the masked Loki is laying
on a beach usually that would make me
happy but here we are so at the costume
party where he has his first appearance
of the mask they have a huge song and
dance number and it's supposed to be
like nearing the one in the first I
think and I was actively frowning
throughout it and I took a video on my
phone because I wanted you to see
[Music]
like I said he wants to be an animator
and he shows up the next day and of
course the head animator at his company
like I saw you at the party last night
you had to spark he's like I'm gonna
give you this job and then so he gets
this job and he's terrible at it
stop this blatant mess someone stop why
have I done this to myself I just wanna
play boss his wife gets pregnant while
he was in the mask and now they're
having a child of the mask and she
throws up bubbles and she eats
silly-string on a cracker and she's
doing wacky things while being pregnant
I actually liked that that's a fun
exploration of what would happen if you
had sex with someone while wearing the
mask it was cute
I enjoyed that and then right back to
the bad stuff right just straight on
right back in it was like go whale
breaching for air and coming back down
the dark depths of the ocean the Odin
makeup is bad it is bad and that is
coming from someone who's like this
right now so then the dog Otis turns
into the mask so funny
oh my god then Avery the mask baby
covers his father in piss and it's
supposed to be funny I think
but it's aggressively unfunny and it's
creepy and there's like one stream and
then another stream and like gallons of
yellow and the down is just taking it in
just like wow you stinker and like an
uncomfortable amount of pee happening
trump would look a lot is happening in
this and by that i mean nothing at all
loki finds them but his dad takes away
his powers and then the baby defeats
loki and then loki it's his powers back
he takes the kid and then the dad loses
his jobs I already say that the dad was
this job and then it's this whole fight
at the end between Loki and the dad as
the mask as he apologized to his dog
Otis were not being attention to him
think sorry man but I have a baby now
we're dogs like all right bro we cool
and it was so dumb every single
consequence in this film every conflict
was so easily resolved mostly from the
dad just being like sorry man I really
messed up I'm the worst I was like
guests Loki and Avery the baby played
twister and the baby tickles Loki with
his ear and it's a really creepy cake
face out and comes in and he takes
Loki's powers away then they work things
out the dad and the son reunite and the
mom is like oh you crazy kids what's
going on then Tim gets to be an animator
of a terrible show they watch that and
the wife is like but I'm pregnant again
and he's like what we had no idea and
it's like you need to speak about having
kids before you have kids this is the
worst one November so far check me out
next week with Birdemic thanks for
watching I'm Tamara chambers and I'm
never having kids
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you